one of the narratives that's been built
up by the right wing
during the biden presidency and in
particular they were they were building
this up during the lead up to last
week's biden putin summit
was the joe biden dementia narrative
it's not a new narrative remember that
back when the 2020
democratic primary was going on
when it got down to just joe biden
versus bernie sanders
many right wingers and even some people
on the left were saying
this is when biden falls apart this is
when
in a one-on-one debate against bernie
sanders
joe biden becomes completely unable to
put together a single coherent sentence
and it just didn't happen as we know but
they've continued to push this narrative
during the biden presidency sometimes
it's saying you know it's really kamala
harris who's running the show biden
can't do anything he's just
uh you know he's an empty suit and
someone else is controlling him
uh sometimes it's saying biden can't do
anything without notes
imagine right being prepared for
meetings that's what i call it
and every single one of these claims
that now is when it'll really become
clear biden can't even
uh he doesn't even know what day it is
um every single time
it fails to materialize but they were
pushing it again for the biden putin
summit
it didn't happen but it also didn't
happen
and it didn't matter that it didn't
happen because in the aftermath
they were still saying whoa did you see
biden
really concerning behavior and here is
ronnie jackson this was donald trump's
white house doctor for a while
now a congressman ronnie jackson went on
fox news and said
from what i'm seeing joe biden really
needs
a cognitive test that montreal cognitive
assessment that trump took
and then ronnie says remember trump got
a perfect score on that test and then
walks that back and says well he did
really well
yeah we submitted to that president
trump as you mentioned he did he hit a
perfect score on his cognitive test an
outstanding performance
and i i'm just saying now i'm saying
that is the new standard
the the precedent has been set and i'm
asking joe biden and his medical team
to get out there and to get this
physical exam done get this cognitive
testing done and get the results back to
the american people
we need to know that we can trust our
president now there is just
so much here to talk about uh first of
all
notice that ronnie jackson first says
trump got a perfect score
then he walked it back and said well it
was an outstanding performance
what he's referring to is when donald
trump took that montreal cognitive
assessment which is really meant to
screen out
serious dementia it's like what city are
you in
can you identify whether a drawing is a
lizard or a tiger
trump didn't get a perfect score but
even if trump did get a perfect score it
wouldn't tell us that much
you're really supposed to get a
near-perfect score
unless you're seriously cognitively
struggling you give that test
to people you suspect have pretty
serious dementia
or they've suffered a stroke and you
want to evaluate how they're doing
cognitively at a high level
or maybe there's been a brain injury etc
the idea that trump's near perfect score
on that test is now a baseline for
evaluating joe biden
it's it's all a backwards series of
events
saying trump's score was great on that
so biden should take it
is like saying i got a really good score
on a drug test well it's like no you
just weren't using drugs there was the
absence of a drug problem
the test is meant to screen out the
presence or absence of
serious cognitive issues if the new
standard
is knowing that a camel isn't a shark
and that you know we're in washington dc
then we're in real trouble
and then for a doctor to go on tv and
say
this bare bones test to rule out severe
dementia
is now the standard for the presidency
that's scary as well now let's get back
to the biden dementia stuff
i have been saying without any
hesitation
or equivocation since day one of joe
biden's 2020 candidacy
joe biden is not the same joe biden
as in 2012 when he debated and ran
circles around paul ryan joe biden's
speech has slowed down over the last
decade
joe biden is almost 80 years old i've
conceded that as if it's even really a
concession
i've also talked about how joe biden's
lifelong stutter
combined with him being nearly 80 and
just talking more slowly
now could make it seem as though maybe
he's not 100 clear in his mind all the
time i have no interest in gaslighting
it can appear that way when you combine
the slowed down speech with the stutter
but when you see biden given the
opportunity to lay out his thoughts in a
normal setting you realize that the
guy's memory easily recalls even small
details
about conversations that took place last
week and about conversations that took
place last decade
he has a full understanding of the
context of every issue he's asked about
and i have no question right now about
his ability to do the job
particularly compared to donald trump
orders of magnitude
better now is this the same guy that was
joe biden
debating paul ryan in 2012 of course not
and
along the same lines if you look in an
uh at an
interview at an interview uh that now
i'm having the issue
uh at an interview that trump did with
dave letterman 12 years ago
trump's facility with words his
vocabulary his entire way of speaking
has also shifted dramatically and one of
the things you notice with trump
which can be a concerning sign is his
vocabulary
is so limited compared to how he spoke
a decade or two ago in those interviews
with dave letterman and others
now if i thought joe biden was having a
real cognitive issue i would just tell
you
period i have no more interest in having
a president
with a cognitive issue than i guess any
republican does although they seemed not
as worried about it
when trump couldn't identify that rudy
giuliani was across the table from him
or couldn't identify that his limo was
right in front of him when he got off
air force one and walked down
and had to be brought back by secret
service uh or when he said he wanted to
get to the oranges
of an investigation the same people now
concerned about biden weren't concerned
then
i've called it like i've seen it all
along but to hear this
from ronnie jackson the guy doesn't even
have experience
selecting and conducting these types of
tests he's the guy who told us trump is
six foot three
and weighs 239 if you can believe that
and even people with mild dementia
can actually pass the montreal cognitive
assessment so that's the latest from
ronnie
they're continuing to push this same
thing and
i'm curious to hear from you what you
make of it are they pushing this because
they have nothing else
are they pushing it to sort of sort of
try to get back
at the concerns about the same with
donald trump i don't know
let me know what you think we'll have
more on this on the show's
instagram which you can find at david
pakman show
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely free
service
at privacy.com pacman i've been using
privacy for a little over a year now
you've heard me talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plug-in
let you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number
you're keeping your identity private by
not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free
and like i said you'll get five dollars
to spend when you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman